je peux te faire confiance
[Musique]
bien sûr
je peux te faire confiance
toujours
il y a 8 ans vous étiez deux des
meilleurs agents de citadelle mais l'un
des nôtres nous a trahis et vos
souvenirs ont été effacés je vous ai
fait venir parce que j'ai besoin de
votre aide j'entraîne des gosses au
baseball ça c'est mon champion
alors qu'il est tous leurs agents à
travers le monde sont à votre recherche
Nadia
c'est toi qui va le regretter
[Musique]
je me souviens d'absolument
celui qui nous a trahi s'apprête à
déclencher un cataclysme
on était ensemble vous vous flattez
jamais
je suis exceptionnellement douée pour
convertir les agents de site internet
c'était vous
mais ça ne doit jamais savoir vous
m'avez dit de vous faire confiance
depuis quand vous m'écoutez on ne peut
pas me faire confiance je suis en espion
on a été piégé il y a plus personne
c'est toi et moi maintenant
tout ce que vous savez
est un mensonge
[Musique]